in this lecture we introduced the notion
of a random variable a random variable
is loosely speaking a numerical quantity
whose value is determined by the outcome
of a probabilistic experiment the weight
of a randomly selected student is one
example after giving a general
definition we will focus exclusively on
discrete random variables these are
random variables that take values in
finite or countably infinite sets for
example random variables that take
integer values are discrete twenty
discrete random variable we will
associate a probability mass function
which tells us the likelihood of each
possible value of the random variable
then we will go over a few examples and
introduce some common types of random
variables and finally we will introduce
a new concept the expected value of a
random variable also called
the expectation or mean it is a weighted
average of the values of the random
variable weighted according to their
respective probabilities and has an
intuitive interpretation as the average
value we expect to see if we repeat the
same probabilistic experiment
independently a large number of times
expected values play a central role in
probability theory we will look into
some of their properties and we will
also calculate the expected values of
the example random variables that we
will have introduced